un français est devenu plus riche
qu'arnaud lagardère juste en achetant un
ticket de loterie parce que c'est la
comparaison qui a été fait
voilà pour moi sont plus arnaud
lagardère est très sympathique et est
devenu 410e fortune de france ou pas oui
oui on est content 100 millions de suez
millions d'euros le jackpot record de
200 millions d'euros a été remporté
vendredi soir par un français je vous le
dis personne n'a dévoilé son identité
moi je voulais dire ce soir il s'agit de
monsieur vdo velits sur 140 millions et
ouais il a gagné 200 millions d'euros au
regard des îles on entend parler partout
c'est le plus gros gain de l'histoire de
l'histoire c'est grand c'est bien sûr
mal et bien sûr à ce qu aux etats unis
900 grammes et on doit gagner 1,537
c'est ça oui il ya ces sauvegardes $
milliards
avec un tel capital
on peut voir grand s'acheter deux airbus
a320 mais peut-on pour autant tous
offrir la réponse est non amoureux de
foot le joueur neymar a coûté la
bagatelle de 222 millions d'euros au psg
mba paix en revanche entre dans le
budget et pour ceux qui se voit déjà en
haut de la fiche 200 millions d'euros
c'est le budget du dernier film avengers
le gagnant se hisse à la 410e place des
hommes les plus riches de france c'est
énorme
et pourtant ces 500 fois moins que
bernard arnault première fortune du pays
dans ses comparaisons dire ils
pourraient s'acheter une belle maison
comme celle ci la mer 12 rb à dessein
meilleure fenêtre mais tu crois moi que
si tu gagnes 200 millions va acheter
deux airbus qui sont sortis chez toi et
moi j'étais des noës angolais qu'est-ce
que tu joue au loto
non je me suis on a joué ici on n'a pas
eu un bon numéro
ah oui c'est vrai allez vous poser la
question qu'est ce que vous auriez fait
avec mais vous les avez déjà donc c'est
bon allez
[Musique]
vous jouiez vous un petit peu louche
propre et surtout s'est jamais produit
proposé reste à les voir aller faire un
bel automne et printemps